- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
다시 오신 걸 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고
IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 여섯 번째 강의이고, 양자 알고리즘에 관한
시리즈 두 번째 단원의 두 번째 강의예요.
지난 강의에서 우리는 계산의 질의
모델에 대해 이야기했고, 그 모델에서 양자 알고리즘이
놀라운 이점을 제공할 수 있다는 걸 봤어요.
고전 알고리즘에 비해서요. Simon 문제의 경우에는 지수적 이점까지 포함해서요.
안타깝게도 질의
모델은 직접적이거나 즉각적인
실용적 관련성이 별로 없어요.
블랙박스라는 개념은 알고 보면 매우 유용한
추상화인데, 우리가 적용하려면
좀 더 해야 할 일이 있어요.
질의 모델에서
얻은 통찰을 입력이 비트 문자열로 주어지는 좀 더 표준적인 계산 환경에 적용하려면요.
오라클이나 블랙박스가 아니라요.
이 강의의 주요 목적은 그것을 할 수 있는
기반을 마련하는 거예요.
강의 개요를 보면요. 강의의 대부분에서 우리는
계산 비용에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
다시 말해, 다양한
계산 작업이 얼마나 어렵고 그 어려움을 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지에 대해서요.
대략적으로 말하면, 이건 계산이 끝나길
얼마나 오래 기다려야 하는지, 궁극적으로 어떤
계산 문제를
풀 수 있고 어떤 것이
우리의 능력 밖인지로 이어져요.
몇 가지 예시부터
시작할 거예요. 정수 인수분해와 최대공약수,
줄여서 GCD 계산이에요.
이것들은 기본 원리를 설명하는 데 아주 좋은 예시이고,
둘 다 다음 강의에서 다룰 Shor 알고리즘과
매우 관련이 깊어요.
그래서 이 예시들로
두 배의 효과를 얻을 수 있을 거예요.
그런 다음 계산 비용의 개념을 좀 더 일반적으로 그리고 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지 이야기할 거예요.
이걸 할 수 있는 방법은
여러 가지가 있지만, circuit 모델의 계산에
꽤 좁게 초점을 맞출 거예요.
구체적으로 Boolean circuit과
quantum circuit이요.
여기서 초점은 예를 들어 컴퓨터
하드웨어가 아니라 알고리즘에 맞춰져 있고, 우리는 더 관심이 있어요.
알고리즘 실행 비용이 문제 인스턴스의 크기가 커질수록
어떻게 변하는지에 대해서요.
몇 초, 몇 분,
몇 시간이 걸리는지 같은
특정 계산 시간보다는요.
이런 관점을 이끄는 아이디어는 알고리즘이
근본적인 중요성을 가진다는 거예요.
오늘날까지도 우리는
아주 아주 오래전에 개발된 알고리즘을 여전히 실행하고 있고, 매우 자연스럽게 기술이 발전함에 따라
더 빠르고 더 안정적인 하드웨어를 사용해서
점점 더 큰 문제 인스턴스에 적용될 거예요.
그리고 그것들이 어떻게 확장되는지가 그것들이 얼마나 유용하고
앞으로도 얼마나 유용할지에 대해 많은 걸 알려줘요.
강의의 마지막 섹션에서는 매우 중요한 작업으로 넘어갈 건데, 바로 고전 계산을
양자 컴퓨터에서 실행하는 거예요. 이것이 중요한 이유는 고전 컴퓨터를
양자 컴퓨터로 대체하고 싶어서가 아니에요.
그건 곧 일어날 것 같지 않고 영원히 안 일어날 수도 있는데, 오히려 이것이 열어주는 건
양자 알고리즘을 위한
많은 흥미로운 가능성이에요.
구체적으로, 고전 계산을 양자 컴퓨터에서
실행하는 방법을 알게 되면, 양자 알고리즘의
서브루틴으로 사용할 수 있게 돼요.
그래서 양자 계산 이점을 추구하면서
고전 알고리즘에 대해 알고 있는 모든 것을 효과적으로 활용할 수 있어요.
오늘날 우리가 가진 고전 컴퓨터는 정말로 기술의 경이로운 산물이에요.
엄청나게 빠르지만, 어떤 계산 문제도
능력 밖이 아닐 만큼 빠르지는 않아요.
어떤 계산 문제들은 본질적으로 너무 어려워서
그것을 풀 알고리즘이 있긴 하지만, 오늘날 지구상의 어떤 컴퓨터도
사람의 수명 안에, 심지어
적당한 크기의 입력에 대해서도 이 알고리즘을 끝까지 실행할 만큼 빠르지 않아요.
심지어 지구 자체의
수명 안에서도요.
더 자세히 설명하기 위해,
정수 인수분해 문제를 살펴볼게요.
문제 설명은 아주 간단해요. 문제의 입력은 2 이상의 정수 N이고, 출력은
N의 소인수분해예요.
그게 의미하는 건 N의 소수 인수들의 목록과 함께 이 소수들을 곱해서
N을 얻기 위해 올려야 하는
거듭제곱이에요.
물론 소인수들을 어떤 순서로든 곱할 수 있지만, 순서를 제외하면
소인수분해는 모든 N의 선택에 대해 항상 유일해요.
그 사실은 산술의
기본 정리라고 불리고, 더 알고 싶으시면
많은 정수론 책의
맨 처음 부분에서
찾을 수 있어요.
아주 간단한 예로, 숫자 12의
소인수분해를 보여드릴게요.
2의 2제곱 곱하기
3의 1제곱이에요.
당연하게도, 컴퓨터는
소인수를 반복적으로 검색하는 것만으로 눈 깜짝할 사이에 알려줄 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시가 있어요. 이 숫자를 읽어보진 않을게요.
약 3.4 콰투오르데실리온인데, 이런 이름이 있다는 것 자체가 좀 이상하다고 인정할 수밖에 없어요.
어쨌든, 46개의 십진 자릿수를 가지고 있고 여기서
소인수분해를 볼 수 있어요.
컴퓨터도 이걸 알려줄 수 있어요. 저는 Python용 기호 수학 라이브러리에 포함된
인수분해 방법을 사용해서 이 숫자를 인수분해했어요.
몇 초 걸렸는데, 특별히 긴 시간은 아니지만 눈에 띄는 지연이 있었어요.
물론 factor N 방법은 소인수를 단순하게 검색해서 이 소인수분해를 찾지는 않아요.
실제로는 여러 알고리즘의 하이브리드를 사용하는데,
그중 하나가 colored row 알고리즘이에요. 이건 소인수를
단순하게 반복 검색하는 것보다
더 정교한 인수분해 알고리즘이에요.
꽤 큰 숫자처럼 보일 수 있지만,
계산 문제의 입력으로서는 사실 그렇게 크지 않아요.
겨우 46글자에 불과해요.
하나 더 예시가 있어요. 309개의 십진 자릿수를 가진 숫자예요.
이진 표기법으로 쓰면 1,024비트를 가지고 있고 그래서
RSA1024라고 불려요.
이 숫자의 소인수분해는 현재 알려져 있지 않아요.
이 숫자는 RSA Laboratories가
1991년부터 2007년까지 운영한 RSA 인수분해 챌린지에서 나온 거예요.
이 숫자를 포함해서 점점 커지는
다양한 숫자들의 소인수분해에 상금을 걸었는데,
이건 10만 달러짜리였어요.
하지만 그 상금은 수여된 적이 없어요.
RSA 공개키 암호 시스템의 보안은
정수 인수분해의 어려움에 기반하고 있어요.
인수분해를 할 수 있으면
시스템을 깨뜨릴 수 있어요. 그래서 챌린지의 목적은 기본적으로
인수분해의 최신 기술 수준을 추적하는 거였어요.
결론은 이 숫자를
인수분해하는 것은 현재 우리 능력 밖이라는 거예요.
우리가 아는 한, 이 문제 자체가
고전 컴퓨터로 실제로 풀기엔 너무 복잡해요.
참고로, 지금까지 인수분해된 가장 큰 RSA 챌린지 숫자는 250개의 십진 자릿수를 가지고 있어요.
화면에서 읽기 좀 어려울 수 있는데,
RSA250의 소인수분해가 여기 있어요.
이건 2020년에 수체 체(number field sieve)라는 알고리즘을 사용해서 이뤄졌고, 전 세계 수만 대의
컴퓨터가 참여한 집단적 노력이었어요.
자, 이제 다른 계산 문제를
생각해 볼게요. 두 비음수 정수의 최대공약수,
줄여서 GCD를 계산하는 문제예요.
두 비음수 정수의요.
문제의 설명은 이래요. 입력은 이번에는
두 개의 숫자, N과 M으로 구성돼요.
둘 다 0인 경우는
아니라고 가정할 거예요.
목표는 이 두 숫자의
GCD를 계산하는 거예요. N과 M을 모두 나누어 떨어지게 하는 가장 큰 정수 D예요.
N과 M의 소인수분해를
생각해 보면, GCD는 N과 M 모두를 나누는 모든 소수의 곱이에요.
두 소인수분해에 나타나는 거듭제곱의 최솟값으로
올린 거예요.
그래서 정수 인수분해 문제와
관련이 있지만, 컴퓨터로 풀기에는 훨씬, 훨씬 더 쉬워요.
수천 자릿수의 숫자에 대해서도
눈 깜짝할 사이에 GCD를 계산할 수 있어요.
화면에 예시를 보여드리는 건 좀 무의미해요. 화면 전체를 숫자로 채워도
여전히 이 문제의
쉽게 풀 수 있는 인스턴스를 설명하는 거일 테니까요.
하지만 관심이 있으시면, 동영상 설명의 링크를 따라가서 이 강의의 교재 페이지를 보시면 코드 셀을 찾을 수 있어요.
제가 말하는 종류의 계산들인데,
큰 숫자의 GCD를 계산하는 것도 포함돼 있고,
직접 시도해 볼 수 있어요.
질문은 왜 GCD를 이렇게 쉽게 계산할 수 있느냐는 거예요.
그 질문에 대한 답은 GCD를 계산하는
효율적인 알고리즘이 있다는 거예요.
그중에는 2,000년 이상 전에 발견된 유클리드 알고리즘이 있지만, 다른 효율적인
GCD 알고리즘들도 있어요.
물론 여기서 고전 알고리즘에 대해 이야기하고 있는 거니까, 또 다른 질문이 나와요.
RSA1024 같은 숫자를
눈 깜짝할 사이에 인수분해할 수 있게 해주는
효율적인 고전 알고리즘이 있을 수 있을까요?
답은 네, 있을 수 있어요. 인수분해를 위한 효율적인 고전
알고리즘이 절대적으로 있을 수 있고, 현재로서는 그 가능성을
배제할 방법을 모르겠어요. 우리가 말할 수 있는 건
아직 하나를 찾지 못했다는 것뿐이에요.
우리가 아는 모든 고전
인수분해 알고리즘에서 우리는 본질적으로 여전히
인수를 검색하고 있고
그래서 RSA1024 같은 숫자는
우리의 능력 밖이에요.
반면에 효율적인 GCD 알고리즘은
그런 방식으로 작동하지 않아요.
최대공약수를 검색하지 않아요.
같은 두 숫자를 곱하는 것과 비슷한 비용의
기계적 절차로 효과적으로 만들어내요.
이에 대해서는 강의
후반부에서 좀 더 이야기할게요.
물론 이 모든 것은 다음 강의에서 볼
Shor 알고리즘으로 이어지고 있어요. 이건 소인수분해를 위한 효율적인 양자 알고리즘이에요.
하지만 거기에 도달하기 전에 아직
다뤄야 할 내용이 좀 있어요.
다음으로 다양한 알고리즘의
계산 비용을 측정할 수 있는 수학적 프레임워크에 대해 이야기할 거예요.
이미 이야기한 것들도 포함해서요.
분명히 말하면, circuit에 아주 좁게 초점을 맞출 거예요.
이건 훨씬 더 넓은 주제의 작은 부분에 불과해요.
지난 강의에서의 일반적인 계산에 대한 매우 높은 수준의 관점부터 시작해 볼게요.
특히 질의 문제를 생각하는 게 아니라
입력이 이진 문자열로
명시적으로 주어지는 문제를 생각하는 거예요.
지난 강의에서 말했듯이, 원한다면 다른 기호를
허용할 수도 있지만, 간단하게 이진 문자열을 고수할게요.
입력과 출력 모두에 대해서요.
계산 자체는 튜링 머신 계산 모델 같은
다양한 방식으로 모델링하거나 설명할 수 있어요.
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit, 또는 Python이나
다른 언어로 작성된 프로그램으로요.
방금 말했듯이, Boolean과 quantum
circuit에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
먼저, 이진 문자열이라고 가정하는 입력과 출력에 대해 좀 더 시간을 들여 이야기해 볼게요.
이진 문자열을 사용하면, 숫자, 벡터,
행렬, 그래프 같은 많은 종류의
수학적 객체를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
예를 들어 분자의 설명이라든지, 이 모든 객체들의 목록과 다른 것들도요.
아주 간단한 예로, 비음수 정수를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하려면 이진 표기법을 사용하면 돼요.
이 표에서 처음 13개의 비음수 정수와 함께
그 이진 표현 또는 인코딩을 볼 수 있어요.
여기 세 번째 열에서 각 인코딩의 길이를 볼 수 있는데,
이건 인코딩에 필요한 총 비트 수예요.
그리고 여기에 임의의 비음수 정수 N에 대해 일반적으로
몇 비트가 필요한지 정확히 알려주는 간단한 공식이 있어요.
특히 인코딩의 길이가 일반적으로
숫자 자체보다 훨씬 작다는 점에 주목하세요.
숫자에 대해 로그적이에요.
예를 들어 RSA1024는 길이 1,024의 인코딩을 가지지만,
숫자 자체는 물론 그보다 훨씬 커요.
이 인코딩 방식은 비음수 정수에 대해서 작동하지만,
음수를 포함한 임의의 정수를 다루고 싶으면
부호 비트를 추가하면 돼요.
인코딩이 고정 크기의 비트 블록이나 레지스터를 채우도록
하고 싶으면 선행 0을 얼마든지 허용할 수도 있어요.
충분히 크기만 하면요. 때로는 그게 아주 편리해요.
이건 정수를 비트 문자열로 인코딩하는 유일한 방법은 아니에요.
다른 방법들도 있지만, 이건
꽤 표준적인 방법이에요.
우리가 관심 있는 계산 문제의 입력이나 출력을 형성할 수 있는
다른 종류의 객체에 대해서도 다른 인코딩 방식을 만들 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 벡터나 그래프를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 생각해 보거나
두 개의 이진 문자열을 공백이나 다른 기호 없이
0과 1만 사용해서 하나의 이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 생각해 보세요.
이런 것들을 하는 방법은 분명히 있고,
사실 정확히 어떻게 하는지에 대해 많은 자유가 있어요.
종종 우리가 말하는 것을 이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 단 하나의 표준적이거나
보편적으로 합의된 방법은 없을 거예요.
하지만 괜찮아요. 하나를 고르거나 원하면 새로운 걸 만들면 돼요.
순수하게 형식적인 관점에서, 우리는 계산을 본질적으로 비트 문자열에 대한 기계적 변환으로 생각해요.
우리가 사용하는 인코딩 방식의
세부사항은 어느 정도 수준에서는 확실히 중요해요.
하지만 그럼에도 불구하고, 알고리즘을 설계하고
분석할 때, 인코딩 방식의 세부사항에 대해 보통 그렇게 많이 걱정하지 않아요.
두 명의 다른 사람에게 특정 유형의 분자를
이진 문자열로 인코딩하는 방법을 만들어 달라고 하면
다른 방법을 제안할 수 있겠지만, 자기가 뭘 하는지 아는 합리적인 사람들이라면
두 인코딩 방식 사이를 변환하는 것이 꽤 간단한
계산 과정이 될 거라고 합리적으로 기대할 수 있어요.
아마 우리가 실제로 관심 있는 계산에 비하면
매우 간단한 계산이 될 거예요.
결론은 우리가 사용하는 인코딩 방식에 관한 세부사항은 종종 꽤 부차적이고 우리의 초점은
알고리즘 자체에 있다는 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 이게 문제가 되지 않을 거예요. 이진으로 인코딩된다고 가정하는 정수에 관한 문제에 주로 초점을 맞출 거지만,
알아두면 좋은 내용이에요.
일반적으로, 어떤 종류의 문제를 다루든, 입력 길이는
입력을 인코딩하는 데 필요한 비트 수를 의미해요.
그리고 입력 길이를 우리가 생각하는 문제의 인스턴스 크기로 봐요.
이제, 이 그림에서 파란색 직사각형으로
표현된 계산 자체를 살펴볼게요.
이 계산의 비용을 측정하는 방법은
필요한 기본 연산의 수를 세는 거예요.
직관적으로 말하면, 기본 연산은 작고 고정된
수의 비트나 qubit에 관한 연산이에요.
예를 들어 두 비트의 AND를 계산하는 것처럼
빠르고 쉽게 수행할 수 있는 연산이요.
형식적인 수준에서,
사용하는 계산 모델에 따라 기본 연산을 정의하는
다양한 방법이 있어요.
예를 들어, 튜링 머신 모델을 사용한다면 기본 연산은 튜링 머신의 한 단계가 될 수 있어요.
이 강의에서는 이미 말했듯이 circuit 모델에 초점을 맞출 거예요. 구체적으로 quantum
circuit과 Boolean circuit이요.
circuit으로 작업할 때는, 각 gate를 기본 연산으로 생각하는 게 일반적이에요.
시리즈에서 지금까지 여러 가지 quantum gate를 봤는데,
X, Y, Z gate, Hadamard gate, S와 T gate,
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate, 그리고 Fredkin gate를 포함해서요.
질의 모델의 맥락에서 query gate에 대해서도 이야기했지만, 이 강의에서는 질의 모델 안에서 작업하지 않을 거니까
지금은 query gate에 대해 걱정하지 않을게요.
또한 임의의 수의 qubit에 대한 모든 유니터리 연산을
원하면 gate로 볼 수 있다는 것도 봤어요.
하지만 비용을 측정하는 목적으로는 그건 별로 도움이 안 되니까, gate의 집합을 선택하고
그 집합을 기본 연산의 집합으로 볼 거예요.
먼저, 여기 보이는
단일 qubit 유니터리 gate를 포함할 거예요.
X, Y, Z gate,
Hadamard gate, S와 T gate, 그리고 그것들의 역행렬
또는 켤레 전치를 포함해서요.
이 gate들이 전부 필요한 건 아니에요. Hadamard와 T gate만 있으면 나머지를 구현할 수 있어요.
하지만 편의를 위해 전부 포함할 거예요.
controlled NOT gate도 포함할 건데, 이것들이 우리 집합에서
유일한 다중 qubit gate가 될 거예요.
마지막으로 단일 qubit 표준 기저 측정을 포함해서
circuit에서 실제로 고전 정보를 얻을 수 있게 할 거예요.
유니터리 gate에만 초점을 맞추고 측정을
잠시 잊으면, 이른바 보편적 gate 집합을 얻게 돼요.
그게 의미하는 건 임의의 수의 qubit에 대한
모든 유니터리 연산을 정확히 구현하거나
이 gate들만으로 만든
quantum circuit으로 임의로 가깝게 구현할 수 있다는 거예요.
다시 말해, 이것들로 모든 유니터리
연산을 만들 수 있는 충분한 gate 집합이에요.
반드시 정확하게는 아니지만, 원하는 만큼
좋은 근사를 얻을 수 있어요.
많은 gate가 필요할 수 있고, 때때로 많은 gate가
필요할 수밖에 없다는 걸 추론하는 건 사실 어렵지 않아요.
하지만 그럼에도 불구하고 항상 가능해요.
이것이 보편적 gate 집합이라는 걸 증명하는 건 간단한 문제가 아닌데요.
시리즈에서 어떻게 하는지는 다루지 않을 거예요.
하지만 이건 꽤 잘 알려진 사실이고 증명할 수 있는
다양한 방법이 있어요.
이것 대신 때때로 사용되는 다른 gate 집합도 있어요.
Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate, S gate에 측정을 더한 것 같은 거요.
하지만 이건 꽤 표준적인 선택이에요.
그래서 요약하면, 이것들이 우리가
기본적이라고 볼 양자 연산이에요.
Boolean circuit에서는
이 네 가지 gate를 기본 연산으로 간주할 거예요: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate, 그리고 FANOUT이요.
참고로 FANOUT은 항상
gate로 간주되지는 않지만, 강의 후반에서 보겠지만
이걸 gate로 세는 게 중요할 거예요.
표준 quantum gate 집합과 비슷하게,
이 집합도 약간 중복돼요.
AND와 OR 둘 다 필요하지 않아요. NOT gate 세 개와 함께 다른 하나를 사용해서 어느 쪽이든 만들 수 있어요.
하지만 둘 다 포함해도 문제없고 그냥 편리해요.
이미 아실 수 있듯이, 이건 결정론적 계산을 위한
보편적 gate 집합이에요. 비트에서 비트로의 모든 함수를
이 컬렉션의 gate로 구성된 Boolean circuit으로 구현할 수 있다는 뜻이에요.
다시 한번, quantum circuit에서와
마찬가지로, 모든 함수가 Boolean circuit으로 효율적으로 구현될 수 있다는 뜻은 아니에요.
실제로 대부분의 함수는 매우 큰 circuit으로만
구현할 수 있어요. 단순히 함수가 매우 많고
작은 circuit으로 전부 커버할 수 없기 때문이에요.
작은 circuit이 충분하지 않아요.
보편성은 양자의 경우보다
이 경우에 증명하기가 더 쉬워요.
그래서 증명하는 방법을 아직 모르신다면,
관심이 있으시다면 한번 생각해 보고 알아낼 수 있는지 해보세요.
이제 허용하고 기본 연산으로 간주할
gate를 정했으니, 그것들이 얼마나 많이
다양한 계산을 수행하는 데
필요한지 생각할 수 있어요.
그러기 위해 circuit의
크기에 대한 이 정의를 사용할 거예요.
이 정의는 Boolean과 quantum
circuit 모두에 작동하고 아주 간단해요.
circuit의 크기는
총 gate 수예요.
예를 들어, 우리가 여러 번 본
같은 예시로 돌아가면, 두 비트의 배타적 OR를 계산하는 Boolean circuit이에요.
크기가 7인 걸 볼 수 있어요.
FANOUT gate 2개, NOT gate 2개,
AND gate 2개, OR gate 1개, 총 7개의 gate가 있으니까요. FANOUT gate를 세지 않기로 하면
(이게 일반적인데) 크기는 5가 되겠지만,
우리는 FANOUT gate를 셀 거니까 크기는 7이에요.
circuit의 크기는
수행해야 하는 기본 연산의 수에 해당해요.
그 연산들을 순차적으로 수행한다면
크기가 얼마나 걸리는지 알려주니까
circuit 크기를 순차적 실행 시간으로 생각할 수 있어요.
이것이 이 강의에서 계산 비용을
측정하는 방법이 될 거예요.
하지만 circuit을 실행하는 데 필요한 시간으로
볼 수 있는 또 다른 속성이 있는데,
그건 circuit의 깊이예요.
정확하게 말하면, 깊이는 입력 와이어에서
출력 와이어까지의 경로에서 만나는 gate의 최대 수예요.
이건 circuit을 만드는 데 필요한 gate 층의 수와 동일한데,
층이란 공통 와이어가 없어서
동시에 수행할 수 있는
gate 묶음을 말해요.
예를 들어, 아까의 circuit은
깊이가 4이고, 다이어그램에서 직접 4개의 층을 볼 수 있어요.
FANOUT gate들은 동시에
수행할 수 있고, NOT gate들도
동시에 수행할 수 있고, AND gate들도
마찬가지로 동시에 수행할 수 있어요.
그래서 circuit 깊이를 병렬 실행 시간으로 생각할 수 있어요.
circuit 깊이는 확실히 흥미롭고 중요한 개념이고, 일부 계산에 필요한
깊이를 줄이는 데 사용할 수 있는
매우 정교한 기법들이 있어요. 때로는 실제로 상당히 극적으로요. 하지만 이건 고급 주제이고
이 시리즈에서 이에 대해 더 많이 이야기하진 않을 거예요.
다시 한번 말하면, 계산 비용을
circuit 크기, 다시 말해
계산을 수행하는 데 필요한 기본 연산의 수로 측정할 거예요.
강의 시작 부분에서 정수 인수분해 문제에 대해 이야기했고,
이 문제를 풀기 위한 알고리즘에 필요한 시간이
입력 길이가 늘어나면 증가할 수 있다는 걸 봤어요.
이것이 보통 우리가 초점을 맞추는 문제예요.
알고리즘을 분석할 때요.
즉, 입력이 점점 커질수록 알고리즘 실행 비용이 어떻게 변하는지에 관심이 있어요.
물론, 이런 확장성만이 중요한 건 아니에요.
예를 들어, 단순히 RSA1024의 인수를 찾는 것에만
관심이 있을 수도 있어요. 그게 전부요.
그런 경우에는 아무것도 커지지 않는
단일 문제 인스턴스에 대해 이야기하는 거예요.
하지만 알고리즘에 대해 생각할 때, 비용이
어떻게 변하는지가 매우 중요하고 알고리즘에 대해
많은 것을 알려줘요.
이 관점은 알고리즘이
근본적이라는 아이디어와 일치해요. 전에 이야기했듯이
시간이 지나고 기술이 발전하면, 점점 더 큰
입력에 대해 적용될 거예요.
하지만 계산 문제의 입력은
크기가 커질 수 있지만 circuit은 커지지 않는다는 점을 주목하세요.
각 circuit은 고정된 크기를 가지고 있어요.
그래서 circuit을 사용해서 알고리즘을 설명하려면
실제로 circuit의 패밀리가 필요해요.
circuit의 패밀리란 입력을 수용할 수 있도록
점점 커지는 circuit 모음을 말해요.
입력이 점점 커지니까요. 예를 들어, 정수 인수분해 문제에 대한
고전 결정론적 알고리즘을 생각해 볼게요.
시행 나눗셈에 기반한 것일 수 있지만, 이 예시에서
구체적인 방법은 별로 중요하지 않아요.
이 예시의 목적상요.
원칙적으로 이런 알고리즘을 Boolean circuit의 패밀리로 설명할 수 있는데,
인수분해하려는 숫자의
이진 표현이 N비트라면, 패밀리에서 circuit CN을 가져와서
인수분해하려는 숫자를
그 circuit의 입력 비트에 넣으면 돼요.
때로는 이 circuit들을 다른 방식으로 매개변수화할 수 있어서,
N번째 circuit이 항상 N개의 입력 비트를 가지는 건 아닐 수 있지만
꽤 전형적인 방법이에요. 자연스럽게
입력 길이가 길어지면 이 패밀리의 circuit이 더 커질 거라고 예상하는데
이건 예를 들어 4비트 숫자를
인수분해하는 것이 1,024비트 숫자를 인수분해하는 것보다 훨씬 쉽다는 사실을 반영해요.
그래서, 이를 염두에 두면, 이런 알고리즘의 비용을
각 가능한 입력 길이에 대해 얼마나 많은 기본 연산이
필요한지 알려주는 함수로 측정해요. 이건 고전과 양자 알고리즘 모두에 적용할 수 있어요.
예로, 인수분해나
GCD 계산보다 확실히 훨씬 간단한 정수 덧셈 문제를 생각해 볼게요.
정수 덧셈이요.
간단하게, N과 M이 모두 비음수 정수이고
같은 길이의 이진 문자열로 표현된다고 가정할게요.
같은 길이의요.
이 두 숫자를 더하는 Boolean circuit을 어떻게 만들 수 있을까요?
표준 덧셈 알고리즘부터 시작해 볼게요. 이건 우리 모두 연필과 종이로 숫자를 더하는 방법으로
배운 것의 2진법 버전이에요. 가장 덜 중요한
비트부터 시작해서
더하면 결과의 가장 덜 중요한 비트와 함께
다음 자리에서 고려해야 할 올림 비트가 나와요.
비트를 따라 계속 진행하면서 출력 비트와
올림 비트를 생성해요.
끝에 도달할 때까지요.
이 방법은 Boolean circuit으로
꽤 직접적으로 표현할 수 있어요.
한 가지 방법은 두 개의 1비트 정수를 더하는 작은 circuit부터 시작하는 거예요.
그러면 0에서 2 사이의 숫자가 나오는데,
덜 중요한 비트는 입력 비트들의 XOR이고
더 중요한 비트, 즉 올림 비트는 두 입력 비트의 AND예요.
이 두 연산을 함께 수행하는 circuit을
반가산기라고 부르기도 해요.
입력 비트가 두 개뿐일 때는
잘 작동하지만, 각각 1비트 이상인 정수를 더하려면
올림 비트를 어떻게든
처리해야 해요.
그래서 할 수 있는 건 두 개의 반가산기를
직렬 연결하고 생성되는 올림 비트의 OR을 취해서
전가산기라는 걸 만드는 거예요.
이건 기본적으로 세 개의 1비트
숫자를 더하는 Boolean circuit이에요.
전가산기가 있으면, 가장 덜 중요한 비트부터
가장 중요한 비트까지 직렬 연결해서 숫자를 더할 수 있어요.
기본적으로 전가산기를 사용해서 올림 비트를 처리하면서
표준 덧셈 알고리즘을 구현하는 거예요.
이 계산의 비용은 얼마일까요?
각 XOR gate에 7개의 기본
gate가 필요하니까 반가산기에는 10개의 gate가 필요하고
따라서 전가산기에는 21개의 gate가 필요해요. 반가산기 두 개에 OR gate 하나니까요.
결국, 입력 숫자가 모두 N비트라면, 가장 덜 중요한 비트에
반가산기 하나가 필요하고
나머지 모든 비트에 전가산기가 필요해서, 최종 결과는 21 곱하기 N 빼기 1 더하기 10, 즉 총 21N 빼기 11개의 gate예요.
만약 어떤 이유로 FANOUT gate를 세지 않고
XOR gate를 gate 집합에 포함시키기로 하면
총 5N 빼기 3개의 gate가 필요해요.
정수 덧셈 같은 다양한 계산을 수행하는 데 정확히 몇 개의 gate나 기본 연산이 필요한지 아는 건 좋은 일이에요.
방금 정수 덧셈에서 본 것처럼요.
물론 이 계산들을 실제로 구현하려면 이런 세부사항을 알아야 해요.
하지만 특히 더 복잡한 알고리즘에 대해 항상 이 정도로 자세하게 들어가면,
세부사항에 금방 파묻히게 될 거예요.
많은 경우에 부차적인
중요성을 가진 세부사항에요.
알고리즘 분석에서 매우 흔한 일을
단순화하는 한 가지 방법은 빅-O 표기법을 사용하는 거예요.
이를 통해 성장률을 꽤 간단하고
매우 편리한 방식으로 표현하고 비교할 수 있어요.
여기 이 표기법의 기반이 되는 정의를 볼 수 있어요.
두 함수 G와 H가 있다고 가정해요.
간단하게 비음수 정수 값을 취한다고 생각할 수 있지만
실제로 꼭 그래야 하는 건 아니에요. G와 H가 예를 들어 다른 계산의 비용을 나타낸다고 할 수 있어요.
그러면 G가 H의 빅-O라고 말하는데, 이건 전통적으로
이렇게 등호로 써요.
N이 충분히 크기만 하면 G(N)이
어떤 양의 상수 C 곱하기 H(N) 이하인 경우에요.
이건 N이 커질 때
무슨 일이 일어나는지에 관한 거예요.
형식적으로, 충분히 크다는 것은 어떤 N_0의 선택이 있어서 N이 최소 N_0일 때마다
부등식이 참이라는 뜻이에요.
핵심은 이 숫자들 C와
N_0가 고정되어 있다는 거예요.
어떤 숫자든 될 수 있지만,
어떤 숫자든 N이 커져도 변하면 안 돼요.
이런 종류의 정의를 처음 보시면
익숙해지는 데 시간이 좀 걸릴 수 있고, 이 개념을
이 강의보다 훨씬 더 자세하게
설명하는 자료를 찾을 수 있어요.
보통 우리가 하는 건 함수 G가 얼마나 빨리 커지는지에 대한
무언가를 표현하기 위해 함수 H를 간단하게 선택하는 거예요.
예를 들어, 17 곱하기 N의 세제곱 빼기 257
곱하기 N의 제곱 더하기 65,537인 함수는
N의 세제곱의 빅-O이고, 이 예시를 정의에 맞출 수 있어요.
C와 N_0를 적절히 선택하면요.
예를 들어, C를 18로 잡으면 N이 충분히 크기만 하면
그 표현식이 실제로 18 곱하기 N의 세제곱 이하가 돼요.
이 표기법을 정수 덧셈 예시에
다시 연결하면, 비음수 정수를 더하기 위한 Boolean circuit의 패밀리가 존재해서
N번째 circuit, 즉 길이 N의 입력에 대해 작동하는 것의 크기가
N의 빅-O라고 말할 수 있어요. 우리 분석에 따른
CN의 실제 크기는 21 곱하기 N 빼기 11이었지만,
그건 N의 빅-O예요.
이렇게 세부사항을 버리는 게 항상 현명한 건 아니지만, 여기서는 말이 돼요.
표준 덧셈 알고리즘의 본질적인 성격을 드러내 주니까요. 비용이 더하는 숫자의 크기에
선형적으로 증가한다는 거예요.
이 표현은 정확히 어떤 gate를 기본 연산으로 보는지 같은
모델의 저수준 세부사항에 민감하지 않아요.
예를 들어요.
예를 들어, XOR gate를 기본 연산으로 간주하거나 FANOUT gate를
gate로 세지 않기로 하거나 둘 다 해도
정수 덧셈이 N의 빅-O 비용으로 계산될 수 있다는 건 변하지 않아요.
계산 문제의 또 다른 예시로
정수 곱셈이 있어요.
덧셈과 마찬가지로, 이 계산의
비용이 얼마인지 물어볼 수 있어요.
표준 곱셈 알고리즘을 생각하면,
즉 초등학교에서 배우는 숫자 곱하기 방법의 2진법 버전인데
이진수로 작업할 때 기본적으로
시프트와 덧셈인 거예요. N비트 정수를 곱하기 위해 크기가 N 제곱의 빅-O인 Boolean circuit이 있어요.
N비트 정수를 곱하기 위해서요.
이건 자세히 다루지 않을게요. 물론 circuit이
덧셈보다 좀 더 복잡하지만, 표준 곱셈 알고리즘이
어떻게 작동하는지 생각하면
놀랄 일은 아니에요.
본질적으로 약 N번의 덧셈이 필요하고,
각각 선형 비용이니까 전체적으로 이차 비용이 나와요.
이건 일반화할 수 있어요. 한 숫자가 N비트이고 다른 숫자가 M비트이면,
크기가 N 곱하기 M의 빅-O인 circuit이 필요해요.
여기서 참고로, 여러 변수가 있는 빅-O 표기법의 확장을 실제로 사용하고 있는데, 이렇게 확장할 수 있어요.
구체적인 세부사항에 관심이 있으시면
강의의 교재 내용을 참고해 주세요.
역시 동영상 설명에 링크되어 있어요.
실제로 두 N비트 정수를 표준 곱셈 알고리즘보다
점근적으로 더 우수한 방법으로 곱할 수 있어요.
특히 Schonhage-Strassen 곱셈 알고리즘은
두 N비트 정수를 N 곱하기 N의 길이 곱하기
N의 길이의 길이의 빅-O 비용으로 곱해요. N이 커지면,
수만 비트 같은 경우,
이게 실제로 더 효율적인 곱셈 방법이지만,
복잡하고 오버헤드 때문에 작은 숫자에는 비실용적이에요.
그럼 곱셈을
예시 목록에 추가할게요.
간단하게, 표준 곱셈 알고리즘이 주는 비용을 나열할게요. N 제곱의 빅-O예요.
다시 한번, 이 비용의 본질적인 성격에 초점을 맞추고 있는 거예요. 이차적으로 증가한다는 것,
또는 점근적으로 더 우수한 방법을 쓰면 이차 이하로요.
정수 나눗셈 문제도
생각할 수 있어요. 화면에 정확히 나와 있어요.
여기서는 몫과 나머지를 계산하는 것에 대해 이야기하고 있어서,
답은 두 정수 Q와 R로 구성돼요.
다시 한번, 나눗셈의 표준 알고리즘이
있고 이것도 이차 비용이에요. 곱셈처럼
점근적으로 더 우수한
알고리즘도 있어요.
그럼 GCD 알고리즘은 어떻게 비교될까요?
유클리드 알고리즘은 이차 비용인 것으로 밝혀졌어요.
강의 앞부분에서 GCD를 계산하는 비용이
두 숫자를 곱하는 비용과 대략 같다고 한 게 바로 이 의미예요.
다시 한번, 덧셈과 곱셈과
비슷한 맥락으로 점근적으로 더 우수한 알고리즘이 있지만
이 경우에는 비용이 좀 더 높아요.
적어도 우리가 아는 한에서는요.
이 목록에 추가할 문제를 하나만 더 언급할게요. 모듈러 거듭제곱이에요.
여기에는 세 개의 입력 숫자
K, M, N이 있고, 목표는
N의 K제곱 모듈로 M을 계산하는 거예요.
이건 M으로 나눈
나머지를 의미해요.
전혀 자명하지 않지만, 모듈러 거듭제곱을 삼차 비용으로 계산할 수 있어요.
N비트 정수에 대해 N 세제곱의 빅-O요.
이걸 하는 방법은 먼저 N의 K제곱을 계산하고 그다음 나머지를 구하는 게 아니에요.
N의 K제곱을 적는 것만으로도 지수적으로 많은 비트가 필요할 수 있어서 그 방식은 안 돼요.
대신, 거듭제곱 알고리즘이라는 걸 사용할 수 있어요.
반복 제곱이라고도 하는데, 모든 걸 모듈로 M으로 하면서
K의 비트를 사용해서 반복적으로 제곱하고
곱하는 방식으로 모든 게 작동하게 해요.
이건 다른 것들보다 더 비싸지만,
수천 비트의 숫자에 대해서도 모듈러 거듭제곱을
꽤 빠르게 수행할 수 있어요.
이 작업들의 비용이 정수 인수분해와 어떻게 비교될까요?
간단하게 시작해서 시행 나눗셈을 생각하면,
입력 숫자의 인수가 2인지 먼저 확인하고
그다음 3을 확인하는 식으로 하면, 꽤 비싼 알고리즘이 나와요.
N 제곱 곱하기 2의 N/2 제곱의 빅-O예요.
각 나눗셈은 이차 시간이 걸리고, 최악의 경우 입력 숫자의 제곱근까지 소인수를 검색해야 해요.
N/2가 거기서 나오는 거예요.
그 지점까지 소인수를 찾지 못했으면
그냥 멈춰도 돼요. 그러면
입력 숫자 자체가 소수인 거니까요.
이건 극도로 비싼데, N이 이 표현식에서 지수로 나타나기 때문이에요.
즉 이 알고리즘은 지수적 비용을 가져요.
반면에, 이 상자 안에 있는 모든 예시는 이른바 다항식 비용을 가져요. N이 거듭제곱되지만
그 거듭제곱은 입력 길이가 커져도
변하지 않는 고정된 숫자예요.
이 경우들에서 거듭제곱은
1, 2, 3이에요.
다항식 대 지수적 비용에 대해 잠시 후에 다시 돌아올 건데,
먼저 인수분해에 대해 아는 것을 마무리할게요.
앞서 수체 체(number field sieve)를 언급했는데,
비용 확장 측면에서 우리가 가진 최고의 인수분해 알고리즘이에요.
사실 이 알고리즘의 비용은 엄밀하게 증명되지 않았어요. 정수론의 미해결 문제들과 연결되어 있거든요.
하지만 이런 식의 비용을
가질 것으로 추측돼요.
이번에는 빅-O가 지수에 있는데,
그 세부사항은 넘어갈게요.
핵심 요점은 시행 나눗셈보다 상당히 나아요.
N이 지수에 나타나긴 하지만
1/3제곱으로 올려져서 훨씬 낮은 비용으로 이어지고, 그래서 이 알고리즘이
RSA250 같은 숫자를 처리할 수 있는 반면
시행 나눗셈은 분명히 못 해요.
하지만 N의 거듭제곱이 지수에 나타난다는 의미에서 여전히 지수적이고, 그 결과
RSA1024 같은 숫자는
여전히 처리할 수 없어요.
다항식 비용 대 지수적 비용에 대해
좀 더 이야기해 볼게요.
알고리즘의 비용이 N의 B제곱의 빅-O이면
다항식 비용을 가진다고 해요.
B는 어떤 양수든 될 수 있지만, 핵심은 B가 고정되어야 한다는 거예요.
입력 길이 N이 커져도
변하지 않아야 해요.
방금 본 예시들, 정수 덧셈, 곱셈, 나눗셈,
GCD 계산, 모듈러 거듭제곱에서
B는 1, 2, 또는 3이었어요.
그래서 이것들은 모두
다항식 비용 알고리즘이에요.
하지만 더 일반적으로 다항식 비용이라고 하면
B는 어떤 양수든 될 수 있어요.
백만이 될 수도 있지만,
고정되어야 해요.
매우 대략적인 추상화로서, 다항식 비용을 가진 알고리즘은
일반적으로 효율적인 알고리즘을 나타내는 것으로 봐요.
확실히 과도한 단순화이지만, 대략적인 지침으로서
다항식 비용 알고리즘은
무차별 대입 방식이나
매우 큰 공간에 대한 완전 탐색과는 반대로
문제의 구조를 활용해서 해를 구성하는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
또는 매우 큰 공간에 대한
완전 탐색과는 반대로요.
물론, 입력 길이 N에 대해 비용이
N의 백만 제곱으로 증가하는 알고리즘은
합리적으로 효율적이라고 볼 수 없고,
큰 입력에 대해 실행할 수 있을 거라고 기대하지도 않을 거예요.
하지만 그래도 N의 백만 제곱 알고리즘조차
풀고 있는 문제의 구조를 어떻게든 반영하는 영리한 무언가를 하고 있는 거예요.
큰 영역에 대한 완전 탐색과 관련된
지수적 비용 증가를 피하기 위해서요.
큰 영역에 대한 완전 탐색이요.
그리고 실제로, 다항식 비용 알고리즘의 발견은
효율성을 향한 첫 단계일 뿐이에요.
중요한 문제에 대해 누군가가 아주 큰 지수를 가진
최초의 다항식 비용 알고리즘을 발견하면
알고리즘 설계자들이 그 지수를 낮추는
개선점을 찾을 거라고 합리적으로 확신할 수 있어요.
본질적으로, 문제에 대한
다항식 비용 알고리즘의 존재를 합리적으로 큰 입력에 대해 그 문제를 풀 수 있는
가능성의 입증으로 생각할 수 있지만, 진정한 효율성에 도달하기까지 아직 많은 작업이 필요할 수 있어요.
복잡도 이론에서는 알고리즘의 비용이 모든 양의 실수 엡실론에 대해
2의 N의 엡실론 제곱의 빅-O이면
준지수적으로 증가한다고 보통 말해요. 준지수적이 아니면
지수적이거나, 2의 2의 N제곱처럼 이중 지수적인
초지수적일 수도 있지만
출력이 초지수적으로 길지 않은 한
모든 문제는 실제로 지수적 비용의 Boolean circuit으로
계산할 수 있어요. 그래서 여기서 중요한 구분은 다항식과
지수적 비용 사이에요.
정수 인수분해를 위한 준지수적 비용의 고전 알고리즘은
알려진 게 없어요.
예를 들어, 수체 체의 비용은 엡실론이 1/3 이하일 때
2의 N의 엡실론 제곱의 빅-O가 아니에요.
그래서 이 정의를 만족하지 않아요.
분명히 매우 영리한 알고리즘이지만, 여전히 체이고 우리는 여전히 효과적으로
주어진 숫자의 인수를 식별하기 위해 매우 큰 공간을 검색하고 있어요.
다음 강의에서 보겠지만, 정수 인수분해를 위한
다항식 비용의 양자 알고리즘이 실제로 있어요.
Shor 알고리즘은 다항식 비용을 가지고, 구체적으로는 모듈러 거듭제곱과 비슷하게 삼차 비용이에요.
여러분이 익숙할 수 있는 또 다른 문제 클래스는
NP-완전 문제 클래스예요.
이 강의에서 NP-완전 문제가 뭔지는 다루지 않을 건데,
관심 있으시면 찾아보세요.
이런 문제들 중 어느 것도
준지수적 비용을 갖지 않는다고 추측돼요.
이건 본질적으로 때때로 지수 시간 가설이라고
불리는 것의 circuit 기반 버전인데, 지금까지 아무도
어떻게 증명하는지 알아내지 못했어요.
사실 NP-완전 문제를 위한 선형 비용 알고리즘이 없다는 것조차 증명할 수 없어요.
적어도 우리가 아는 한, 이 문제들을 위한
믿을 수 없을 만큼 창의적인 알고리즘이 미래에 발견될
가능성을 배제하는 건 정말 어려워요.
다항식과 지수적 비용의
관계를 보여주는 그림이 있어요.
X축에는 우리가 생각하는 문제의 입력 길이가 있고,
Y축은 그 문제를 푸는 비용을 나타내요.
원하시면 문제를 푸는 데
필요한 시간으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
지수적 비용 알고리즘은
이렇게 증가할 수 있어요.
짧은 입력에서는 비용이 특별히 높지 않을 수 있어요.
예를 들어 숫자 12를 인수분해하는 것처럼요.
하지만 입력 길이가 길어지면 비용이 결국 폭발적으로 증가해요.
반면에 다항식 비용 알고리즘은
이런 식으로 증가할 수 있어요.
입력이 길어지면 일반적으로 비용이 여전히 증가하고, 일부 입력에서는 지수적 비용
알고리즘보다 더 비쌀 수도 있어요.
하지만 결국에는 지수적 비용 알고리즘보다
훨씬 덜 비싸질 거고, 지수적 비용 알고리즘이 하는 것과
같은 극단적인 방식으로 폭발하지 않아요.
지수적 비용 알고리즘처럼요.
우리가 기꺼이 지출할 최대 비용이나,
답을 기다릴 최대 시간이 있다고 상상하면
시간으로 생각하시는 걸 선호하신다면, 지수적 비용 알고리즘은
특정 길이까지의 입력에만 작동할 거예요.
반면에 일반적으로 다항식 비용 알고리즘은
더 큰 입력에 대해 문제를 풀 수 있게 해줘요.
그래서 예를 들어 수천 비트의 숫자에 대해
GCD를 쉽게 계산할 수 있지만, 최악의 경우에
이 크기의 숫자를 인수분해할 수는 없어요.
강의의 마지막 부분에서는 양자 컴퓨터에서
고전 계산을 구현하는 것에 주목할 거예요.
더 구체적으로, Boolean circuit으로 수행할 수 있는 모든 계산은
quantum circuit으로도 수행할 수 있다는 걸 볼 거예요.
대략 같은 비용으로요. 게다가 이것은
더 큰 양자 계산 안에서 이 계산들을
서브루틴으로 실행하려면 중요한 깔끔한 방식으로 할 수 있어요.
깔끔하다는 게 무슨 뜻인지는 논의가 더 진행되면 설명할게요.
이 과정에서 Toffoli gate를
사용할 거예요.
Toffoli gate는 controlled-controlled-NOT gate라는 걸 떠올려 보세요.
표준 기저 상태에 대한 작용은
화면에서 보이는 것과 같아요.
Toffoli gate를 AND 함수의
query gate 같은 것으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
문자 그대로 query gate라는 뜻은 아니에요. 강의 시작에서 말했듯이 이 시점에서 질의 모델 안에서
작업하는 게 아니니까요.
하지만 그 작용이 query gate와 같은 패턴을 따라요.
이진 값 A와 B를 AND 함수의 입력으로 생각할 수 있고, query gate처럼
이 값들이 출력의 일부로 그대로 나오고, 함수의 값, 즉 A와 B의 논리 AND가
아래 qubit에 XOR돼요. 자, 우리는 Toffoli gate를 표준 gate 집합에 포함시키지 않았어요.
원하면 마음을 바꿀 수도 있지만, 그럴 필요가 없어요.
대안으로 Hadamard gate,
T와 T 대거 gate, controlled NOT gate를
사용해서 Toffoli gate를 구현할 수 있으니까요. 바로 여기 보이는 것처럼요.
이 특정 circuit이 Toffoli gate를
구현한다는 게 전혀 자명하지 않지만, 실제로 그래요. 제 말을 믿으셔도 되고
직접 다 곱해서 추가 연습을 하셔도 되고, Qiskit이나 Python이나
행렬 곱셈을 하는 소프트웨어에 시키면 돼요.
Qiskit을 사용해서 이걸 한 것을
강의의 교재 내용에서 확인할 수 있어요.
이제 quantum circuit으로 Boolean gate를 시뮬레이션하는 것으로 넘어갈 수 있고,
NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate, Toffoli gate만 있으면 돼요.
이 연산들은 유니터리인 것에 더해 결정론적이고, 때때로 이런
연산을 가역적이라고 설명해요. 사실
가역 계산의 연구는 양자 컴퓨팅보다 앞서고,
이 전체 절차가 실제로 거기서 나온 거예요.
걱정해야 할 Boolean gate는
NOT gate, AND gate, OR gate, 그리고 FANOUT gate예요.
이 gate들을 NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate, Toffoli gate를 사용해서 구현하거나 원하시면 시뮬레이션할 수 있다는 걸 보여줄 거예요.
controlled NOT gate와 Toffoli gate로요.
분명히 하면, 방금 언급한 Boolean gate의 값을 표준 기저 상태의 qubit을
입력으로 줬을 때 계산할 수 있는 quantum circuit을 원하는 거예요.
표준 기저 상태의 qubit을
입력으로 줬을 때요.
임의의 양자 상태 입력에 대한 작용은
평소처럼 선형성에 의해 결정돼요.
NOT gate에 대해서는 특별한 게
필요 없어요. NOT gate는 NOT gate이고 직접 구현할 수 있어요.
OR gate는 Toffoli와
NOT gate를 사용해서 시뮬레이션할 수 있어요.
AND gate는 쉬워요. 특히 방금 전에 Toffoli gate가 본질적으로
AND 함수의 query gate
구현이라고 한 것에 비추면요.
정확하게는, 0 상태로 초기화된 새로운 qubit을 도입하고
그 qubit을 Toffoli gate의 타겟으로 하고
두 입력 qubit을 컨트롤로 하면 돼요.
이런 추가 qubit에는 다양한 이름이 붙는데,
양자 계산에 자주 도입돼요.
이름을 하나 정하자면 작업 공간 qubit이라고 부를게요.
작업 공간 qubit에 대한 일반적인 가정은 0 상태에서 시작하고 끝나면
0 상태로 되돌릴 수 있는 경우가 많다는 거예요.
하지만 항상 그런 건 아니에요.
다이어그램에서 점선 직사각형 안에 ket 0이 있는데,
이 qubit의 초기화가
과정의 일부라는 걸 나타내요. 이런 새로운
qubit이 없으면 이 시뮬레이션을 할 수 없어요.
아래쪽 출력 qubit이 우리가 관심 있는 거예요.
AND 연산의 결과니까요. 나머지 두 개는
기본적으로 쓸모가 없으니까 상자 안에 남겨둘 수 있어요.
사실 이 두 qubit을 없애는 것이 이 AND gate를
시뮬레이션하는 작업의 일부라고 상상할 수도 있어요.
정리해야 할 쓰레기
같은 거예요.
어쨌든 이렇게
AND gate를 시뮬레이션할 수 있어요.
이제 AND gate를 할 수 있으니까, De Morgan 법칙 중
하나를 사용해서 OR gate도 할 수 있어요.
AND gate의 두 입력과 출력에 NOT gate를 넣으면
OR gate가 돼요. 그만큼 간단해요.
마지막은 FANOUT이고, 이건
작업 공간 qubit과 함께 controlled NOT gate만 있으면 돼요.
구체적으로 작업 공간 qubit을
타겟으로 설정하면, 들어오는 표준 기저 상태를 효과적으로 복사하니까
FANOUT gate처럼 작동해요.
이렇게 모든 gate가 준비됐어요.
모든 gate가 준비됐으니 이제 circuit으로 넘어갈 수 있어요.
C라는 Boolean circuit이
있다고 가정해요. 원하는 Boolean circuit이면 뭐든 상관없어요.
AND, OR, NOT, FANOUT gate로
구성되어 있기만 하면요.
T를 C의 gate 수라고 하고, C가 계산하는 함수에 F라는 이름을 붙일게요.
F는 여기 보이는 형태를 가진다고 생각할 수 있어요. N은 C의 입력 비트 수이고
M은 출력 비트 수이고, 시그마는 이진 알파벳이에요.
그리고 C의 gate를 하나씩 순서대로 처리해요.
NOT gate는 그대로 두고 나머지는 방금
설명한 시뮬레이션으로 교체해요.
C가 이렇게 생겼다면, 우리가 얻는 건
이렇게 생긴 circuit R이에요.
이 다이어그램에서 시뮬레이션에 필요한 모든
작업 공간 qubit이 상자에서 꺼내져서 아래에 모여 있어요.
K는 필요한 작업 공간 qubit의 총 수인데,
NOT gate를 제외한 C의 각 gate마다 하나예요.
R의 출력으로는 C의 출력에 해당하는
qubit들이 있고, 여기서는 그 qubit들이
위에 그려져 있어요.
이 모든 것의 끝에서 위에 있든 아닌든
실제로 상관없지만요.
정확하게 말하면, 임의의 N비트 문자열 X에 해당하는
표준 기저 상태에서 R을 실행했다고 가정하면
이 M개의 출력 qubit은 F(X)에 해당하는
표준 기저 상태에 있을 거예요.
AND와 OR gate에서 남은 qubit들도 모두 있어요.
그것들도 처리해야 하고, 다 모으면 어떤 표준 기저 상태에 있을 거예요.
그 표준 기저 상태가 뭐든 문자열 X의 어떤 함수일 수밖에 없고,
그 함수에 G라는 이름을 붙일 거예요.
G는 C의 gate에 의해 결정되는
새로운 함수인데, R이 실행된 후
남은 qubit들이 어떤 상태에 있는지 알려줘요.
G는 F 다음 알파벳이니까 이 함수를 G라고 부르는 이유 중 하나이고,
또 다른 이유는 G가 garbage(쓰레기)의 줄임말이기 때문이에요.
이것들은 전부 쓰레기 qubit이에요. 특히
각 AND gate와 각 OR gate마다 쓰레기 qubit 두 개가 있어요.
필요한 gate의 총 수는
T의 빅-O예요.
C의 각 gate마다 제한된 수의 quantum gate가 필요하니까요.
OR gate가 가장 비싸요. 그건 NOT gate 세 개와 Toffoli gate 하나가 필요하고
Toffoli gate는 표준 gate 집합에서 15개의 gate가 드니까요.
그래서 C의 각 gate마다
R에서 최대 18개의 gate예요.
최적화하고 싶으면 할 수 있지만, 대략적인
점근 분석의 목적상
R은 T의 빅-O개의 gate를 가진다고 말하면 돼요.
원래의 Boolean circuit C가
계산했던 같은 함수 F를 계산하는 데 성공했어요.
C의 크기에 선형인 비용으로요.
이 함수 F를 계산하는 것만
신경 쓴다면 끝이에요.
하지만 안타깝게도 이
쓰레기 qubit들이 있고, 이 쓰레기 qubit들은 일반적으로
양자 알고리즘을 작동하게 하는 간섭 패턴을 망가뜨릴 거예요.
이 circuit R을 더 큰 양자 알고리즘의
서브루틴으로 사용하려 하면요.
하지만 실제로 이 쓰레기를 제거할 수 있고,
그 방법은 circuit R을 역으로 돌릴 수 있다는 사실을 이용하는 거예요.
다시 말해, 거꾸로
실행할 수 있어요.
이것이 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하기 위해, 먼저 R을 실행하고 그다음 R을 역으로 실행한다고 상상해 볼게요.
R 대거로 표현할 수 있어요.
분명히 하면, 이건 R의 gate들을
역순으로 적용하고 각 gate의 역을 취한다는 뜻이에요.
NOT gate, controlled NOT gate, Toffoli gate는
실제로 자기 자신의 역이에요. 그래서 이 gate들로 생각하면
R 대거는 그냥 R의 gate들을
역순으로 적용한 거예요.
하지만 일반적으로, 방금 설명한 방식으로 어떤 유니터리 quantum circuit이든 역으로 실행할 수 있어요.
즉 gate들을 역순으로
적용하고 각 개별 gate를
그 역으로 교체하는 거예요.
이걸 하면, 먼저 R을 실행하고 그다음 R을
역으로 실행하면 아무것도 하지 않는 거와 같아요.
여기처럼 표준 기저 상태에서 시작했다면, 정확히 같은 표준 기저 상태에서 끝나요.
물론 그것만 하는 건 별로 도움이 안 되지만,
추가 qubit 묶음을 도입할 수 있어요. 구체적으로
circuit C의 출력 비트 수인 M개의 qubit이에요.
이 추가 qubit들은 어떤 양자 상태든 될 수 있지만,
작동 방식을 설명하기 위해 어떤 문자열 Y에 해당하는 표준 기저 상태에 있다고 가정할게요.
Y는 M비트 문자열이고, 여기 보이는 것처럼
controlled NOT gate 묶음을 수행할 수 있어요.
이건 효과적으로 F(X) 문자열을
이 아래쪽 M개의 qubit에 저장된
문자열 Y에 XOR해요.
그래서 전체 계산의
출력은 화면에 보이는 것과 같아요.
X와 Y는 임의의 이진 문자열이에요. X는 N비트이고 Y는 M비트이고, K개의 작업 공간 qubit도 필요해요.
R을 실행하면 F(X)를 계산하고 그 문자열이
위쪽 M개의 qubit에 저장되지만, 쓰레기 qubit
묶음도 있어요.
그래서 출력 F(X)를 아래쪽 M개의
qubit에 XOR하고 그다음 R을 역으로 실행해서
쓰레기를 정리해요.
R이 결정론적이라는 게 중요하다는 걸 지적해야 해요.
이 위쪽 M개의 qubit이 대신 표준 기저 상태의 중첩에 있을 수 있다면
이건 제대로 작동하지 않을 거예요.
하지만 R이 결정론적일 때는
제대로 작동해요.
방금 만든 quantum circuit을 원래의 Boolean circuit C와 비교하면,
기본적으로 임의의 함수에 대한
query gate가 작동하는 것과
같은 방식으로 작동하는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
여기서 차이점은 이 모든 게
작동하려면 작업 공간 qubit이 필요하다는 건데, 그 외에는
C가 계산하는 함수에 대한 query gate를
또는 query circuit을 효과적으로 만든 거예요.
참고로, 작업 공간 qubit을 초기 상태로 되돌리는 데도 성공했어요.
그래서 원칙적으로
후속 계산의 작업 공간 qubit으로
재사용할 수 있어요.
원하면 전체 quantum circuit 주위에 상자를 그리고 Q라고 부를 수 있고,
C와의 관계가 더 명확해져요.
circuit Q는 일반적으로
C보다 더 커요. C의 각 gate마다
Q에 몇 개의 quantum gate가 필요하고
중간에 controlled NOT gate도 필요하지만,
그래도 그 수는 C의 크기에 선형이에요.
이건 어떤 Boolean circuit에든 작동하는 완전히 일반적인 절차이고, Q를 최적화하려는 시도를 전혀 하지 않았다는 점도 알아두세요.
특정 circuit C에 대해서는 Q의 크기를 줄이는
방법이 충분히 있을 수 있어요. 필요한
작업 공간 qubit의 수를 줄이는 방법도 포함해서요.
그게 원하는 바라면요. 그리고 이것이
양자 컴퓨터에서 고전 계산을
실행하는 절차예요.
꽤 간단하지만, 할 수 있다는 것이
중요해요.
특히 이걸 할 수 있다는 걸
알게 됐으니, 원하는 모든 고전 계산을 양자 계산 안에서 자유롭게 사용할 수 있어요.
입력이 그대로 나오고 출력이 qubit 묶음에 XOR되는
이 형식을 따르기만 하면요.
query gate에서 있었던 것과 똑같이요.
비용은 선형적으로 증가해요. 예를 들어 정수 덧셈 같은
문제를 위한 quantum circuit을 만들 수 있어요.
곱셈, 나눗셈, GCD 계산, 모듈러 거듭제곱을 위한 것도요.
이 모든 것이 Boolean circuit과 같은 점근적 비용으로 할 수 있어요.
작업 공간 qubit이 필요하지만, 적어도 끝나면 다시
재사용할 수 있어요.
마지막으로 언급할 가치가 있는 것은, 이 방법이 query gate를 구현하는 방법을 제공한다는 거예요.
지난 강의에서 암시했던 거예요.
즉, 어떤 함수 F를 입력으로 받는 질의 알고리즘이 있고,
F를 Boolean circuit으로 계산하는 방법이 있으면
이 절차를 따라서 그 함수에 대한 query gate를 만들고 질의 알고리즘을 실행할 수 있어요.
그게 유용한지 여부는 질의 문제 자체와 달성하려는 것에 달려 있지만, 본질적으로 이
구성은
질의 모델을 좀 더 표준적인 계산 모델에 연결하는 방법을 제공해요.
이것이 어떤 의미에서 Shor의 정수 인수분해 알고리즘이 작동하는 방식이에요.
강의 앞부분에서 이야기한 일부 산술 연산으로
이런 quantum circuit을 만들 거예요.
그렇게 함으로써 quantum circuit에
고전 상태의 중첩에 대해 그 연산들을 평가하는 능력을 부여해요.
그리고 보게 되겠지만, 이것이 정수를 효율적으로 인수분해할 수 있게 해줘요.
이 강의는 여기서 끝이에요. 주로 표준적인 비블랙박스
계산 프레임워크에서 양자 알고리즘의 기반을 마련하는 데 초점을 맞췄어요.
기본 정수론과 관련된 문제들의 렌즈를 통해 주로 계산 비용에 대해 이야기했어요.
계산 작업에 대한 다항식 대 지수적 비용을
논의했고, 고전 계산이 어떻게
quantum circuit에 의해 깔끔하게 쓰레기 없는 방식으로 구현되어 더 큰 양자 계산의 서브루틴으로
사용될 수 있는지 봤어요.
다음 강의에 함께해 주시길 바라요. Shor 알고리즘이 이 아이디어들을 어떻게 활용해서
다항식 비용으로 정수를 인수분해할 수 있게 하는지 볼 거예요.
그때까지 안녕히 계세요.